JAY: So thank you everybody
for coming for the session.
It's very nice that you managed
to take some time for this most
important event of our life,
that we eventually face.
So I've been very honored
to have Giriraj Swami here
at Google for this talk
on "Authors" series.
Giriraj Swami started
on the spiritual path
when he was just a teenager,
doing his graduation
at Brandeis College in Boston.
And just like many of
us, he was questioning
about the purpose of life, why
there should be death, and what
is the goal of life,
and all these questions.
And he came across
the "Bhagavad Gita,"
which is 5,000-year-old
traditional literature from
India that explains a
spiritual philosophy of life.
And he immediately
became attracted to it,
and found that it answered all
his questions satisfactorily.
And after his
graduation, he started
to dedicate himself
completely on the spot.
And of course, his
parents didn't like it,
so his father tempted him
with a $ 1 million check.
Give up your spiritual path, and
I'll give you this right away.
His father was a
very reputed lawyer
who became, later,
a judge in Chicago.
But such a person which
such integrity that he is,
Giriraj Swami
said, no, I'm fine.
And then, he
continued on the spot.
And he spent the
rest of his life--
and he is still
doing-- dedicated
to the service of educating
others on the spiritual path
that he has so nicely
been able to utilize.
And his teacher had
very ambitious goals,
and he had him go back to India.
His teacher came
from India, but he
had some of his Western
students go back to India,
because India was
losing its culture.
Even though the
spiritual culture
is so well-known in
India, people hardly
take it seriously.
And he said, actually, you
should go back and serve
in India, and see how others
are taking their own culture so
seriously.
They'll wake up and
take it more seriously.
So he sent him to
several ashrams.
He helped him open
several ashrams in India.
And you know how there is so
much politics, and a completely
different language, and
mosquitoes, and whatnot.
But he dedicated his entire
youth and a large part
of his life in helping set
up many of those ashrams,
where people could benefit
from these teachings.
And now, he's spending his time
mostly in Carpinteria, where
he's writing books about
his life experiences,
and everything he has
learned from both himself
and he learned from others.
And he gives lectures
at various universities
worldwide and
other institutions,
on these teachings.
So with that brief introduction,
we are very honored to welcome.
Let's welcome him
with a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
GIRIRAJ SWAMI: So I am
pleased to see you all here.
The thought of death
is not very palatable.
In fact, many people tend
to avoid the thought of it,
so the fact that you've
come is quite encouraging.
Why should the living
think of death and dying?
One entrepreneur
from the area said
that when he was young,
about 17 years old,
he heard or read that "if you
live each day as if it was
your last day, one
day you'll be right.
It will be your last day."
And that statement made
an impression on him.
And in the morning, when he
would look in the mirror,
he would ask himself, if
this were my last day,
what would I be doing?
Would I be doing what I'm
going to be doing today?
And he said that if for too
many days in a row, what
he was going to be doing that
day is not what he would want
to be doing if it was
his last day, he thought,
I have to make some adjustment.
So the contemplation
of death can actually
help us bring into focus our
values and priorities in life,
which is very important.
My spiritual teacher
gave the example
that if you are performing
a complicated mathematical
calculation and you make a
mistake in the first step,
even if you perform all
the other steps perfectly,
you may end up getting
further and further away
from the actual
answer, because you
made a mistake in
the first step.
So the "Bhagavad Gita" explains
what is our actual identity.
I mean, pretty much
everyone is interested
in their self-interest,
which is natural.
You are, I am, everyone is.
But to know what our
real self-interest is,
we have to know what or
who our real self is.
And the "Bhagavad Gita" tells
us that that self, that "atma"--
"atma" means "self"--
is not material.
It's not physical or chemical.
Now, you're all logical
and intelligent people.
We can just consider
two possibilities.
One is that consciousness arises
from a combination of material
elements.
And the other is that it
is a distinct energy, which
is not physical or chemical.
Now logically, if
consciousness arises
from a combination
of material elements,
and when that combination breaks
down, which people commonly
call "death," then we
should be able to restore
that combination and
bring consciousness back
into that dead body.
But our experience has
shown that we can't do that.
With anything material, you can.
I mean, if your car breaks
down, it's not functioning,
you find the defective part.
You can replace it, and
the car will work again.
But once the consciousness
leaves the body, it's gone.
At that precise moment,
practically all the chemicals
or material ingredients
to the body are the same.
That moment when
that consciousness
leaves, the elements before and
after are practically the same.
But some things go on.
And that something is the atma.
And that is of a different
quality than the body.
The "Bhagavad Gita"
gives the example
that the body is a machine.
And the atma is the person
who animates the machine.
As long as the driver is in
the machine, the machine works.
And as soon as the driver
leaves the machine,
the machine can't work anymore.
So we have to consider
which is more important.
I mean, both are important,
the driver and the machine.
But definitely, the
driver's more important.
If there is a car
crash, a disastrous car
crash, and the medics
and police and everyone
rushes to the site, their first
concern is to save the people.
They'll deal with
the vehicles later,
but they want to save
the people first.
So we need to know who we are.
Then, we can really
fulfill our self-interest.
And the "Bhagavad Gita" says
that person is the atma.
Now, where does death come in?
Well, first of all, according
to the "Bhagavad Gita,"
there is no such thing as death.
Because the body, the
machine, is always dead.
It never actually is alive.
But it appears to
be alive, because
of the presence of the atma.
But that atma has
its own requirements,
just like the body does.
And if we pay too much
attention to the body
and neglect the needs of the
atma, we will feel frustrated.
And many people do.
Before writing this book,
I met one of the leaders
in the field of hospice
and palliative medicine.
He is, I think, executive
vice president of the American
Association for Hospice
and Palliative Care.
And at the time, he was a
real pioneer in the field.
So I met him, and
I told him that we
were planning to construct a
hospice in a place in India
where people
especially go to die,
because they consider it's
auspicious for their next life.
And a colleague of
mine, who was a nurse,
mentioned that we
were going to try
to give the patients the
best of care physically,
and emotionally,
and spiritually.
And she expressed her
opinion that in India, people
are a little shy about
dealing with the emotional.
And the doctor, Porter
Storey, he replied,
"Focus on the spiritual.
The physical and mental or
emotional are just temporary."
And I was surprised
and impressed.
This regular, Western-trained
medical doctor
had that realization.
But that comes from dealing
with people who are dying.
You can actually
perceive, in a subtle way,
how their atma is becoming
detached from the body.
And they, themselves--
if they're fortunate--
can actually feel their
spiritual essence.
Yeah.
One colleague of mine-- when
he was approaching death,
he said that, all of our
life, we consider death
to be something to fear.
But when you get
that close to death--
he had a degenerative disease
that just leads you inevitably
to death, ALS, or commonly
known as Lou Gehrig's disease.
He could feel it.
He was just inevitably,
whatever, inch by inch
approaching that point.
And he said that when you
get that close to death,
you realize that it's not
something to be feared.
It's not something
horrible, but it's actually
a portal, an opening to your
true spiritual identity.
And it's actually a
portal beckoning you
beyond this world of matter
to new possibilities.
And that it also helps you
realize your spiritual nature,
which you can fulfill
without leaving your body,
without even coming close
to the point of death,
just by understanding
who you actually are,
and by being aware of
the fact that death
could come at any moment.
In the "Bhagavad Gita,"
the speaker is Krishna.
And he is giving
spiritual instruction.
We call it a spiritual science.
It's not a question
of any sectarian view.
The word "Hindu" is nowhere
in the "Bhagavad "Gita."
It has nothing to do with being
Hindu, or Christian, or Muslim,
or Buddhist.
But it's a spiritual science
that applies to everyone.
And Arjuna was faced
with the possibility
of either killing his enemy--
it was on a battlefield--
or being killed.
And Krishna explained
that there is no death.
You cannot kill anyone.
So by your warfare, to the
soul may leave the body.
Or by their aggression
against you,
your soul might leave the body.
But actually, there is no death.
That soul-- that
atma, I should say--
that atma has no birth or death.
And this is a very
important point.
Not only is it really
us, and not only is it
distinct from matter, but
it has no birth or death.
It has no beginning or end.
It continues.
And that is what everyone wants.
They want life
that will continue.
Whatever fear we have in this
world, and we all have fears.
Fears of getting sick, fears
of losing our position,
fears of being
humiliated, so many fears.
But whatever the fear is,
it pales in significance
compared to the fear of death.
We take so many precautions
not to fall ill.
But ultimately, what we
really don't want is to die.
And that is a fear
that we all have.
But when you realize-- and
that's what my friend said,
that when you realize
that you're not
the body, that
you're something else
and that you'll continue to
exist even after you leave
the body, then you're
freed from fear.
Fear of death.
If you've freed
from fear of death,
it means you're
freed from all fear.
And that is a relief.
Can you imagine what a
happy life that would be,
without fear?
It doesn't mean that we
don't take precaution.
That's something else.
As long as we're in
the material world,
we have to take precaution.
But we know that
nothing can touch us.
The great philosopher
Socrates, he
was attacked philosophically and
verbally, and even physically,
for his belief.
And he would have used a
different word in his language,
but of the atma.
And so the authorities
apprehended them,
and they threatened
him with death.
And then finally, they said, how
do you want to be dealt with?
And he said, "First of
all, you have to catch me.
Then, you can deal with me."
In other words, they
were in possession
of his physical body,
but that wasn't him.
And they couldn't
actually touch him.
So knowing that we're the
atma, that we're not the body,
and that the atma
will continue to exist
after the demise of
the body, it is worth
considering where we go
after we leave that body.
It's just like you're
living in an apartment,
and the apartment is condemned.
You know you're going
to have to leave it.
So we don't want to spend
our last days or hours
in the apartment just trying
to enjoy the apartment,
like the people on
the "Titanic" partying
until the ship went down.
But we want to think, OK, where
am I going to go from here?
And any sane person
would do that.
If they know their
house is condemned.
so the "Bhagavad Gita"
explains what possibilities
exist, as to where
we can go, what
different destinations exist.
And it also tells us
the means by which
we can reach those
different destinations.
And so that's really
our responsibility,
to consider where we want to go
and not just be sort of tossed
helplessly in the ocean
of material existence
by the waves of
material existence.
But really consider, OK, yeah.
I am going to have to leave
this apartment, this vehicle.
Where do I want to go,
and how do I get there?
And in brief, the
"Bhagavad Gita"
explains that just
as on this planet,
there are many
relativities of places.
Some places are more opulent,
and some are more meager.
Some are more abundant.
Some are more meager.
You get different types
of bodies and minds.
Some bodies, by
nature, are stronger.
Some are weaker.
Some intelligence is
greater, and some is lesser.
And you can determine
what body you
get by your activities in life,
and especially your thoughts
at the time of death.
The "Bhagavad Gita"
explains that whatever
you're thinking of
at the time of death,
that determines what state you
will attain in your next life.
And so this is a
very critical moment.
It's like the final exam.
It's the final exam of
our life, because it
determines our future.
In school, you
may go to classes,
do assignments, and
read, and do everything.
But if you fail the
final, you don't graduate.
You have to start
all over again.
So life is also a teacher.
It's a great teacher.
We are meant to learn
important lessons from life.
And what we have learned is
tested at the time of death.
So if we think of
something eternal,
spiritual, and the "Bhagavad
Gita" gives details,
then you will attain to an
eternal, spiritual situation.
And if you think of
something material,
you'll attain to a
material situation.
And there are varieties,
as I've mentioned.
You can be materially more
fortunate or materially less
fortunate.
But as long as you're
in the material world
from one point of view,
you're already unfortunate,
because you are
going to be suffering
in this whatever body you get.
Whether it's a prince or a
pauper, you're going to suffer.
Birth is painful.
Disease, old age, and death
itself can be very painful.
So we want to become free
from all of those miseries,
and that is possible.
Now often, when people speak
about spiritual matters,
spiritual goals,
spiritual destinations,
it can sound impersonal.
Like even within the
Vedic literature,
there's a nice example that
the atma is like a spark,
and the jiva-atma
is like a fire.
So when the spark
falls out of the fire,
it loses its fiery quality.
It's just like a
cinder, a dead cinder.
But that cinder, if it
goes back in the fire,
it's ignited again.
It dances in the fire.
Yes.
But that spark-- this is
the point I want to make.
That spark is a person, and
the fire is a big person.
Not persons like the
body, but the atma.
In fact, that big spark has its
own name, which is param-atma.
Now, we can understand
this logically, also.
Because again, if we
analyze, personality
could be caused either by the
consciousness-- the atma--
or the body.
Now, when the atma
leaves the body,
there's no more
personality in the body.
We love people.
We adore people.
We hate people, thinking
of them as the body.
But when the atma
leaves the body, we cry.
I mean, if we love
the person, we cry.
"Oh, my father is gone.
My father is gone."
Well, why do you say
your father is gone?
He's right there
lying on the bed.
"No, my father is gone.
My father is gone."
Because the atma is gone.
That's your real father.
During his life, you might have
identified him as the body,
but when the atma
leaves the body,
you know that body is not him.
So the person is the
atma, not the body.
The eyes, the nose, the years,
the tongue-- all the parts
of the body are there,
but the person is gone.
So that atma is the
person, not the body.
And so the param-atma,
the supreme person,
is also a person.
And according to the "Bhagavad
Gita," if that supreme person--
if you think of the param-atma
at the time of death, then
you go to the param-atma.
And because you're
a person, jiva-atma,
and he is a person, param-atma,
so you have a relationship.
You can have a relationship
when there's common factors.
I mean, yet in
principle, we could
have a relationship
with an amoeba.
But we don't share
that much in common,
so we can't have that
much of relationship.
But we can have relationships
with human beings,
because we have more
in common with them.
And if they speak
the same language,
the potential for a relationship
is even greater, and so many
things.
So the atma, jiva-atma, has the
potential for a relationship
with the param-atma, because
they're both atmas, spiritual,
and persons.
And they have a
natural relationship,
because the jiva-atma is like
a part of the param-atma.
And we are satisfied in that
position in that relationship.
Otherwise, we're not.
We're not fully satisfied.
And that Dr. Porter Storey,
who I mentioned earlier,
he said that's one of the
great gifts of dealing
with people who are dying.
Because when they
say confront death,
they're not just interested
in accumulating more stuff.
There's a common
saying, something like,
"the one who has the most toys
at the end of the day wins."
But it's not true.
Of course, now-- I mean, this
is a little bit of an aside--
but now, there's
a lot of concern
about old people
losing their memories.
This is another big--
the "Bhagavad Gita" says
we should be aware
of these miseries.
"Janma-mrtyu-jara-vyadhi."
"Janma" means "birth," "mrytu"
"death," "jara," "old age,"
and "vyadhi," "disease."
According to statistics,
baby boomers--
they're more worried about
losing their faculties
than they are about
dying, because there's
so many of these diseases,
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's, so
many.
You don't even know who you are.
It's like, I don't need
to discuss in detail.
So one author, sort
of making a play
on that saying that "whoever has
the most toys in the end wins,"
he said, "whoever has the most
marbles left in the end wins."
But actually, at the end, we
lose everything, all our toys,
all our marbles.
We lose everything.
But the one thing we don't
lose is our consciousness.
And if we make that effort
to realize our relationship
with the param-atma,
then that exists.
And that's, in a way,
all that matters.
And that can be realized
even within this very life,
and in this body.
And that process of linking
or reuniting ourselves,
the jiva-atma with
the param-atma,
is called bhakti yoga.
"Bhakti" means-- you could
say "selfless service"
or "devotional service."
And "yoga" means "to
link or connect."
Like we say to yoke oxen,
that English word "yoke"
comes from "yoga."
So "bhakti yoga" means to be
connected or united, reunited
with the param-atma or Krishna.
Krishna is a name
for the param-atma.
But generally, the param-atma,
when we refer to param-atma,
means "within the heart."
The jiva-atma and the param-atma
are both within the area
of the heart when
they are in the body.
And Krishna, he's outside.
And he has his own spiritual
realm that we can enter,
if we think of him
at the time of death.
And so life is like
our preparation
for that final exam.
And if we determine that we
want to have a life eternal,
means no beginning
and no and, full
of knowledge and full of bliss,
then that can be achieved.
Not in this world of flux,
temporary world of matter,
but in the spiritual
realm with Krishna.
The "Bhagavad Gita"
uses the name Krishna.
And the beauty is that
this process makes
us happy in this life, and
it leads to more happiness
after we leave the body.
So I've just given a
little summary here.
And I'd now like
to hear from you,
if you have any questions
or any points you'd
like me to elaborate on.
In a restaurant, the waiter
comes and takes your order
first, but I sort of did it
the other way around here.
Well, let's say I gave
you the appetizers,
and now, you can
place your order,
if you want to hear more
about any particular topic
or ask any questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
One question is, you said that
a human person has a soul.
But do you believe animals--
do they have souls?
GIRIRAJ SWAMI: Yes, that
is a very good question.
So yes, animals do have a soul.
And coming back to
the original point,
that consciousness is due
to the presence of the soul.
The "Bhagavad Gita"
gives the example that
just like the sky is
permeated by sunlight which
is coming from the sun
globe, so similarly, the body
is permeated by consciousness,
which is coming from the atma.
And when the atma
leaves the body--
I've described the ideal, that
it goes to the spiritual realm.
But if it doesn't, it
will enter another body.
And again, depending on
how we've lived our lives
and what we've thought
of at the time of death,
it might be the body of
an animal or a plant.
And we know that
the atma's there,
because they're conscious.
There have been studies
that show, even plants,
they have consciousness.
They respond to pain.
They respond to good music.
So yes.
So we should be careful
with any living creature,
because within that
creature is an atma.
Just like we're atmas,
they are also atmas,
but they're in
that kind of body.
AUDIENCE: I've heard that
certain sects of Buddhism
believe in reincarnation,
and they also
believe that women
come below men
in that reincarnative scale.
Does the "Bhagavad
Gita" also believe
that if you don't live
your life the right way,
you might come back as
a woman, in the sense
that all women
are less than men?
GIRIRAJ SWAMI: The
"Bhagavad Gita"
says if you don't live
your life in the right way,
you'll come back, period.
So we don't want to come back as
a woman or a man, or anything.
We don't want to come back.
It's like saying, if
you fail your final exam
and have to repeat
the course, is it
better to do this or that?
Well, no.
We're not thinking like that.
We're thinking, how do we pass
the final exam and graduate?
AUDIENCE: Can you speak
to your personal journey,
like what got you
interested in this?
And why did you decide to write
a book on a topic like that?
GIRIRAJ SWAMI: Hmmm.
[CHUCKLES] That's
a good question.
Well, as Jay explained in his
introduction, in the '60s,
I was a spiritual seeker.
And fortunately, the
person who I accepted
as my teacher-- and I met
many, really, before I met him,
but I wasn't satisfied
with any of them.
And I think part of
it was because he
said that we are persons.
And the Supreme is
a person, and we
can have a personal
relationship with him.
Almost all the others, whether
from the Buddhist tradition
or Hindu tradition, they were
all on the impersonal side.
That the goal is you just
give up your individuality
and merge, and become
one with the spirit,
or disappear into the void.
And he taught something
very different,
that you're a person, and
the Supreme is a person,
and you can have a
relationship with him.
And that relationship develops
from the moment you understand
who you are, understand the
jiva-atma and the param-atma,
and the relationship
between them.
But there's also a method for
developing that relationship,
and that is to purify
our consciousness.
In other words,
this consciousness
is not something foreign.
It's not like we're trying to
impose something artificial,
or that the tradition is trying,
but it's something natural.
It's like iron is naturally
attracted to a magnet.
But if it's covered by
rust, it won't be attracted.
But if you remove the rust, then
it will naturally be attracted.
So the jiva-atma's naturally
attracted to the param-atma.
But we're covered with rust.
Our minds are covered with
so many misconceptions,
like "I'm the body, and this is
my husband." "This is my wife."
"This is my car." "This is
my investment portfolio."
But we are not any
of those things.
But even though we may
know that in theory,
we still may be attached
to those things.
So we really need to
transfer our attachment.
And this is a very important
point about the time of death,
that whatever we
are most attached to
is what we will think of.
A friend of mine told a story
that he was driving a car,
and it stalled on
the railway tracks.
And you know how it is.
He was fiddling with it,
trying to get it to go.
And then, he looked
up, and he saw
the train was just
bearing down on him.
He thought, this is it.
It's all over.
And the train hit,
and he was chanting.
I didn't mention
that, but that's
the best process for cleansing,
is a repetition of mantra.
So he started chanting.
And at the last moment, he
thought, what will my wife do?
And then, the train hit, and
he lost his consciousness.
Of course, he lived to tell
the story, fortunately.
So we really have
to become attached
to the param-atma,
which is natural.
But that'll be done by a
process of removing that rust.
And that process is
chanting of the mantra.
And the Vedas
recommend specific--
but there are so many, and
even in other traditions.
I used to spend
time in Pakistan.
And I came across a book there
called "The 99 Names of Allah."
And that book mentioned that the
best thing a pious Muslim can
do at the time of death is to
be chanting the name of Allah.
And the best thing his family
members and loved ones can do
is be chanting
the name of Allah.
So if he can't actually chant,
he can at least hear it.
And the same thing is there
in the Hindu tradition.
Instead of, say,
"99 Names of Allah,"
they have "Vishnu sahasranama,"
"1,000 Names of Vishnu."
it's the same idea, to chant
the name at the time of death,
or to be surrounded
by people chanting.
But even then, the mind
is very flickering.
So we really want to
just be so attached.
Sometimes there are
stories of mothers.
Their child is hit by
a car or something.
And they're just imbued
with superhuman strength.
They can lift up the
car, the back of the car,
to get the child out.
Because of that
attachment, which is good,
a mother's attachment.
So if we have that attachment
for the param-atma,
then-- the "Bhagavad Gita"
gives another example
that the body is like dress.
If your mind is
fixed on something,
you might be changing
your clothes.
You hardly are not
even conscious of it.
You're just, OK.
So that's the real
perfection, when
we're so attached
to the param-atma
that the change of
body is like, we've
fixed on the param-atma
in this body,
and we'll stay fixed
on the param-atma.
That's really the perfection.
AUDIENCE: So as
a word of comfort
when you lose a
loved one, can you
think your memories of them--
in fact, part of their soul
is now part of your soul?
GIRIRAJ SWAMI: That's
also a very important part
of this process.
Yes, our own final
exam is important,
but dealing with the loss of
loved ones is also important,
and also helping people who are
grieving for a lost loved one.
We can certainly remember
the person who's left us.
And if we understand
that the atma is eternal,
we'll know that
that person is still
alive in some other form
and some other place.
And it is a fact that when
the atma leaves the body,
it has powers that
were not manifest
when it was in the body.
A colleague of mine
mentioned that he
had a friend who was a
real-- I say "agnostic"
just to be polite.
He was really an atheist.
But I shouldn't even say
that, because it's not
that one's better
than the other.
But he was a real skeptic.
And when his wife left
her body, she visited him.
And here, this is someone who
had no belief in any of this.
He though it was all just
in the mind, all just
wishful thinking.
And then, he got
back to my colleague
and told him what happened.
And he said, you
know, I may have
to conceded that some of the
things that you've been telling
me, which I've been rejecting,
may actually be true.
But if you believe
in prayer, one thing
that you can do that could
only help your loved one,
departed loved one, is
pray for that person.
Again, prayer is something that
can be met with skepticism.
But there have been real,
controlled experiments
with patients.
And none of the patients
knew whether they
were being prayed for or not.
It was a double-blind
experiment.
And the patients that
were being prayed for,
they really did much
better than the patients
who weren't being prayed for,
although they had no idea
that they were being prayed for.
And so much so, that
the beneficial effects
of the prayer was greater
than the beneficial effects
of most of the
medications that had
been tested in
similar experiments.
But anyway, that's up to you.
But certainly, whoever
that loved one is
is alive somewhere
in some situation.
And if that person goes
to the spiritual realm
immediately, or maybe after
another time in the class,
and you also go there, and
you'll really be reunited.
It's not a fantasy or
just wishful thinking.
And some people, as
they approach death,
it's said that that line
between this world in the next,
it becomes sort of permeable.
And things from
beyond the border
sort of come into
their consciousness,
and they can have
amazing revelations.
And there have
been so many books
now about out-of-body
experiences
and near-death experiences.
And so it's possible.
JAY: Once again,
we'd like to thank
Giriraj Swami for this
wonderful lecture.
[APPLAUSE]